العسكريه في اقليمي زابيولوجيا ان الجيش
الروسيه نفذ
124 غاره على البلدات الاوكرانيه الواقعه
على مقربه من خط المواجهه مما اسفر عن
اصابه شخصين وتدمير ثمانيه وعشرين مبنى
ومنشاه زراعيه واضافت انها اسقطت اكثر من
100 قذيفه مدفعيه على اهدافها كما نفذت
القوات الروسيه فماله هجمات بواسطه طائره
مسيره على بلدات عده
على احد المصانع اتعرضت مدينه
نيكولوبشينا الى القصف ثلاث مرات
بالمدفعيه الثقيله
كما اكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط
مسيرتين الاوكرانيتين في اجواء منطقه
كورسك فيما اعلن حاكم مقاطعه
مسيرات في اجواء
غرايفوروزسكي بالمقاطعه اما في القرن
فاعلن الحاكم الروسي لمدينه سباستوبل
احباط هجوم صاروخي قرب مطاري بلبك في سبا
ستوبل
من جانبه قال الجيش الاوكراني ان دفاعاته
الجويه تمكنت من اعتراض 26 طائره مسيره
مفخخه من نوع شاهد من اصل 38 اطلقها الروس
الليله الماضيه باتجاه الاراضي الاوكرانيه
اضاف الجيش 25 اشتباك مسلحا مع القوات
الروسيه على جبهات القتال امس واضح ان
القوات الروسيه شنت 16 هجوما صاروخيا
ونفذت اثنتين وسبعين غاره جويه كما قامت
65 هجوما بمقذوفات صاروخيه متعدده كما اكد
بيان الجيش ان نحو 150 بلده اوكرانيه كانت
في مرمى النيران
كما اعلن الجيش الاوكراني انه قصف
بالتعاون مع جهاز الامن المركزي
صاروخ هاي مارس في بيانه ان القصف ادى
لمقتل ثمانيه من جنود وضباط الجيش الروسي
واصابه سبعه اخرين
افادت الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه في
اقليم يوديسا بان القوات الروسيه هاجمت
ميناء اسماعيل على نهر الدانوب فجر اليوم
بصواريخ وطائرات مسيره مفخخه واضافت
الاداره العسكريه ان قواتها اعترضت معظم
المسيرات الروسيه لكن الهجوم اسفر عن
اصابه شخصين ووقوع اضرار كبيره لحقت
بمبنى حاجز التفتيش والمستودعات
[موسيقى]
معنى من زبيولوجيا مراسلنا الياس كرام
اهلا بك الي
اس قف عسكريا بعد تلك الغارات على مقربه
من خط المواجهه هناك
نعم لعل الابرز هو الهجوم بالطائرات
المسيره هذا الصباح الذي استهدف اقليم
اوديسا وتحديدا ميناء اسماعيل على نهر
الدانوب حيث كان السكان في الجهه الاخرى
للحدود في الاراضي الرومانيه قد شاهدوا
هذا الانفجار الضخم الذي حصل في الميناء
ونجح احد المواطنين الرومانيين من التقاط
صور
لاثار هذا الانفجار الضخم التي الذي طال
ميناء اسماعيل واسفر بحسب السلطات
العسكريه هناك عن اصابه شخصين على الاقل
وتدمير مستودعات الحبوب وبالاضافه الى
اشتعال النيران بنحو 30 شاحنه تجاريه
كبيره
وعدد اخر من الشاحنات الصغيره التي تعرضت
لاضرار جسيمه بالاضافه الى مرافق البناء
التحتيه في هذا البناء ومن الواضح بان
القوات الروس تتعمد منذ اسابيع عده
استهداف ميناء اوديسا وبناء اسماعيل وريني
على نهر الدانوب على اعتبار ان القوات
الروسيه تحاول اولا منع الاوكرانيين من
فتح ممر امن لتصدير الحبوب عبر هذه
الموانئ الى دول العالم بعد انهيار اتفاق
الحبوب وانسحاب روسيا منه وايضا ياتي هذا
الهجوم على اوديسيا وعلى ميناء اي اسماعيل
بعد يوم من الهجوم على ميناء اوديستا
ويبدو ان هذا ايضا يحمل في طياته ردا
عسكريا روسيا على استهداف القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه للقواعد العسكريه الروسيه في
شبه جزيره القرم وكما قال قبل ايام مدير
مكتب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه اندريه بان اي
هجوم على اوكرانيا وعلى موانئها سوف يلحق
برد اوكراني ايضا على الج الروسي عدا عن
ذلك بطبيعه الحال الهجمات الاوكرانيه على
القواعد العسكريه في شبه جزيره القرم
مرتبطه بشكل وثيق مع العمليات العسكريه
المتواصله هنا وهذا الهجوم الرئيسي على
محور زبروجيا حيث يتطلع الجيش الاوكراني
للوصول الى مدينه موريتوبل وهي عقده
اتصالات ومواصلات مهمه جدا شمال القرن
والهجمات التي ننفذها الاوكرانيون ضد
القواعد العسكريه الروسيه هدفها ضرب
القدرات العسكريه الروسيه التي تستخدمها
روسيا من اجل ضرب العمق الاوكراني وايضا
في محاوله لضرب الخطوط الخلفيه للقوات
الروسيه والامدادات التي تاتي من القرن
باتجاه المناطق الشماليه اي باتجاه خرسون
وباتجاه منطقه العمليات هنا في في زبروجيا
فيما يقول الجيش الاوكراني بانه ما زال
يحقق تقدما على محور بيرفيين في محور
الزبروج
شكرا جزيلا لك